[Music]
hey you guys
it's sunday yep we're not even hungover
no i actually feel pretty good yeah i
slept pretty good
i do too i think and honestly not but i
still that's still something yeah
honestly i really like how the show came
out last night because i was like
i drank a lot but i was still like
pretty coherent i thought
and i got like through my entire notes
and i was like really proud of myself
which i don't usually because usually i
get up and i'm like oh [ __ ] i forgot to
say this that the other thing but i
think i got through all my [ __ ] so
go me i guess uh so yeah we threatened
last night that we were going to talk
about this movie today
yeah they're saying no don't do it hey
we reviewed the first one we were in the
first one
it's holly it's uh holidays and this is
a holiday classic anyway
um [ __ ] man [ __ ] this part of the
crustal sphere
it's the christmas christmas yeah yeah
and you know christmas chronicles one to
me i think it's a modern classic that's
been like the best christmas movie a
long time
oh yeah big time yeah this one was i
would say
it was a worthy sequel
it's not as good as the first one i
don't think but it's not really a
christmas movie to me this is more like
a north pole movie
yeah i see what you're saying like
there's a lot of christmas [ __ ] in it
obviously there's like santa it's the
north pole there's elves there's
reindeer there's all that kind of stuff
but i feel like it's kind of like the
days leading up to christmas right
yeah yeah it's not about delivering
christmas and that's what the first one
was about they didn't want to redo
that again yeah so they're taking the
kids to the north pole to show you what
the north how the north pole works
yeah with the elves and [ __ ] they
expanded on the lore
they're showing you yule cats and
[ __ ]
christmas villains and [ __ ] how this
north pole is powered by the damn star
of bethlehem up on a big tower that
[ __ ] powers everything i thought that
was a nice touch
just more christmas technology and magic
yeah it was like um yeah so basically
this was actually
directed by chris columbus who um
obviously very famous probably most
famous for home alone but he also did
mrs doubtfire he did the first two
harry potter movies you know so kind of
a big he did like a lot of big movies in
the 80s
and uh so he didn't do the first one did
he i think that was like a different
director
but so this one it has like all the same
like the same kids in it
you know what i mean like the the two
kids that went to uh you know
that went with santa like in the first
movie but since they're
older like the older brother teddy he's
still
in the movie but he's only like at the
very beginning and the very end
like he doesn't get to go on the
adventure i guess maybe they thought
because he was too old
i don't really yeah they just i don't
think i think they thought that the kid
was
probably a little too grown and too
teenagery to be involved
that's what i was thinking they showed
him but then they don't
they don't really and then you could
tell they tried to make it for a wider
audience you had to have
you wanted to have a white kid and a
black kid up in the north pole which i
agree with that
because you know [ __ ] christmas is a is
a
is a western thing you know and we're
kind of multiracial
so you got to have everybody kind of
involved that's how they did it
even though like christmas that's like
deep deep back in the day in the honky
motherland
what they're talking about but it's
accessible to everybody it's not it's
not celebration it's not ethnocentric
that's that's what they did anybody want
to celebrate christmas however they want
to celebrate it it's
no skin off so the mom the mom from the
first one you know
you know her husband died and she's got
a new she's got a new boyfriend who has
a son
who he's got he's kind of shy and he's
not
and kind of nerdy like he's allergic to
everything very scared of everything and
everything so he's like a little pip
squeaky kind of kid
when they first showed the boyfriend
they showed him from a distance
and [ __ ] i thought that was sucking
um that comic
uh what's his name i can't remember oh
you said it but no i can't remember what
it was
i think that guy that plays my camera
with that actor's name is but i think
that guy
is actually known for comedic roles but
they didn't give him a lot of comedy
he wasn't in it he was only he's only in
like the very beginning in the very end
like yeah you know they don't like do a
lot with him
because you know the the adventure
starts like pretty
uh soon into the thing so yeah so one
enzo has so she has a new
boyfriend and like i said that was
another way to get like a littler kid
because they have the same girl too and
she's like a little bit older i don't
know how old she is now
but um so it's another way to get a
littler kid
involved as well who hasn't been there
before and she's been there so yeah
dave chappelle that's what his name is i
thought you just saw him for like five
minutes from the distance goes man
that's dave chappelle and then
if he's awesome for a minute i thought
it was dave chappelle
and [ __ ] then they kind of zoomed in
on me and i was i was disappointed i was
like oh that's not dave chappelle it
would have been
[ __ ] hilarious if it was dave
chappelle hey hey
hey he's just [ __ ] being corny as
[ __ ] you've been
[ __ ] funny as i'm your mom's
boyfriend you know
[ __ ] dave dave chappelle [ __ ] i
love that [ __ ] his some of his
routines man talking about prince
actually he did prince but he it was in
it was in
um eddie murphy's brother's charlie
murphy's [ __ ] telling a story about
bugging
having pancakes and playing basketball
with prince that's probably my favorite
bit that he
had [ __ ] the couch and [ __ ] yeah
funny as [ __ ] i mean i think everybody
loves that yeah i mean how can you not
love that bit that's like
hilarious but yeah unfortunately it was
not dave chappelle in the movie
yeah it would have been so much better
this guy did okay but it was like good
but like i said this guy i think he's
known for comedic roles but they didn't
really give him any funny
lines he's only in it for like two
minutes or something like like
yeah yeah very beginning it would have
been it would have been
for me it was just been out of bed roll
it if it was dave chappelle
yeah yeah it'd have been [ __ ] funny
as [ __ ] but yeah so
basically what happens with this one is
like it's been i guess it's been like
two years
since the last one i think is about what
the timeline was
and um so the little girl's grown up a
little bit the mom has a new boyfriend
and the little girl
is like not having it because she's kind
of like um you know you're
trying to replace my dad or whatever
because you know how like little tweens
do or whatever
so they've all decided like the the new
boyfriend
has taken them all to cancun for
christmas
and the little girl is just like really
pissed about
this and rightfully so because she's
like does it even seem like christmas
we're on the [ __ ] beach and [ __ ] like
that and i'm like
exactly little girl because that's kind
of like what having christmas in florida
is like
except every year and it sucks so i can
understand like because she's into like
christmas oh it's gonna snow
we can have hot coc hot choc chocolate
and all this other kind of stuff she's
like now we can't do that because now
we're like out on the [ __ ] beach and
it's like summertime and that blows and
it doesn't seem like christmas
badger's in there saying that he liked
it because it wasn't a rehash of the
first one
yeah they did something different yeah i
said the same thing to jenny after we
got done watching it i was like
i said well i don't think it went in a
good direction because they couldn't
remake the first one again
yeah i have to do something new so what
you do is you take
you know it's it's it's a movie for the
whole family so you know that from the
first one the kids are going to
want to know more about the north pole
so they take you to the north pole to
the village
yeah to meet mrs claus and all that [ __ ]
and you know which is uh that that's
crustal's wife uh what's her goalie
honey goldie yeah goldie hawk
so she's like in a lot yeah and she does
a great job which i thought was nice
yeah she does a great job [ __ ] she
can do a bunch of [ __ ] too much
christmas magic exploding cookies
yeah just everything and they showed the
reindeer where the reindeer live it's
all
everything that like a kid would want to
know
about the north pole they kind of
delivered on that
also i liked that the elves were in it
more because nothing i don't know why
this makes me laugh so hard
but even from the first movie where
crustal is speaking
whatever the elvish language was which
sounds kind of like
finnish or something like that or yeah
or something like that when he's like
speaking that to the elves and there's
like that just for some reason that like
just like really yeah
yeah but they have a lot more of this
that a little girl can speak it and she
doesn't know how she can speak it but
she can speak it every now and then yeah
they kind of addressed that in the first
one that that because she's a true
believer that's why
so like when you're a true believer you
can magically like speak the elf
language
like back to them because those elves
are like hilarious
there's a villain in there called bells
nickel yes
played by it looks like a new zealander
kid or something
that kid is on i looked him up and he's
on i don't know where he's from he's
australian or a new zealander uh or a
new zealander i can't remember but um
he's on some other show called
uh [ __ ] hunt for the wilder people or
something like that that's kind of where
he
you know came up he's probably about 14
huh it's hard to tell
because he's like a big boy yeah he's a
big boy he did a great job though and he
did a great job in in the uh
in the role exactly yeah he's basically
i like that they kind of took some
because they still have some like
kind of christian-y trappings like they
have the star of bethlehem and stuff
they don't talk about jesus or nothing
like that but
there is like a star of bethlehem and
that's kind of what's powering
the village and it's also what makes
this
the weird temporal time rift so the time
doesn't pass the same way like in the
normal
or whatever yeah there's like wormholes
and time travel there's all kind of [ __ ]
and uh so they have that but they also
did like some cool
um you know pagan or christmas
uh you know legends so like you said
they had the yule cat who's kind of like
a bad guy which i guess he sort of is
and belsnickel who i think we talked
about bell's nickel and the yule cat on
one of our
like probably our first christmas show
that we did like christmas creatures or
whatever
now bell's nickel it's a germanic thing
and he's basically like a less monstrous
krampus like he's he's the guy that has
he's like has a bag of like candy and
night and presents and stuff for the
good kids but he also has like a whip
like to beat the bad kids
yeah and he like kind of looks like a
like a hobo yeah in this one he just
looks like a regular kid
and uh they explained his nature is
explained as
uh he's a cursed elf yeah see
he started out as an elf and yeah he
kind of went bad
but then he went rogue and then like he
turned into a human and uh you know they
had a pretty good
pretty good time with that story it was
just um
like i said it was a worthy sequel
to to the first one i think i still like
the first one better
the usual number in this one what it was
good but it wasn't quite as [ __ ]
tight as wasn't as rocking as the first
well i mean plus the first one had
hookers yeah it had hookers and
criminals and
grand theft auto could have been this
one didn't have any of that
stuff it could be that i haven't
we had only seen it once maybe on
multiple viewings it sticks with you but
it's a decent sequel to it makes i'm
pretty sure they'll probably make a
third one
they probably will i feel like this
one's getting like wildly mixed reviews
like some people really really loved it
and some people really really hated it
really um yeah i just i feel like i
didn't really see a lot of stuff in
between
but i you know salty [ __ ] salty
[ __ ]
i kind of well it's like i said it's
really not as good as the first one
but i do like that they went in a
completely different i mean it's you
know it's the same it's still
like a christmassy story and it's still
got santa and everything but they did
like a whole different thing and they
opened up like the mythology and
everything like that and they showed you
different [ __ ]
i mean there's still like some of the
same there's there's
you know like um you know the slay fight
or like you know the slay going in and
out like
like in the first one they did that
again but um
you know they they tried to do like
different stuff there's still a lot
that a lot of story that could be told i
mean he hasn't talked about krampus
they haven't talked about a lot of
christmasy stuff
i was kind of hoping krampus would show
maybe cramp as well they're showing the
third one
although they've made it there could be
it could be there's a lot more you can
go a lot of places with this
third movie i mean they've done a lot of
krampus movies like in the last few
years i guess because everybody just
suddenly discovered the krampus legend
and like really liked that idea
you know what i mean so it's like
because so i feel like like a lot of
because there have been like
other than one that was just called
krampus which is actually really good
but there have been like a lot of
asylum level ones too that i saw like on
tubie
and a christmas what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is that anthology movie called the
christmas horror story i think it's
called
or christmas horror stories i don't
remember but it was like four or five
different stories and they had one where
santa and krampus were fighting and also
there were zombie elves it was great
that was like the wraparound story yeah
there was other stories too but like
that had krampus in them
but uh the zombie elves that was [ __ ]
fantastic so if you guys haven't seen
christmas horror story definitely check
that [ __ ] out i don't think there's much
more i can say about this one
probably not like like i said you don't
want to spoil it too much
um i i will say that
i did i don't know if i liked the wrap
around that was in cancun
because for the same reason that the
little girl like in universe the little
girl didn't like it because it didn't
seem like a christmasy movie they were
trying to bring
they're trying to bring christmas
stories to a global audience not
everybody lives in a [ __ ] northern
it in the northern hemisphere you know i
mean up at the top we have the same
problem as like the australians where
they have christmas in the middle of
[ __ ] summer
right yeah and it's like it's it's not
summer down here it's winter but it's
not
cold yeah florida christmas is not
[ __ ]
snow globes and [ __ ] logs on the fire
and [ __ ] you'd be [ __ ] crazy
i like to pretend that it is though it's
like i'm like close all the doors and
turn the air conditioning down really
loud
yeah i mean my my mom and my stepdad
they have a fireplace in their house and
they're like we don't care how hot it is
we're still putting the fireplace up for
christmas christmas
cats isn't definitely gonna catch this
one on the first one the first one is
is you gotta see him the first one is
really good this one is good
yeah it's good the other one the other
one i think is much better i think the
first one i would
you know if i'm going to get star
ratings the first one i'd give five
stars this one maybe three and a half
yeah that's about where i'm going with
it yeah like i said i like that they did
something different i like that they
added like bells nickel and yule cat and
stuff like that that was like that kind
of
um the first one is a tough act to
follow i mean it is
the first one was so good i have to see
this one again
maybe maybe i'd warm up to it on
multiple viewings you know i don't know
yeah you know far to watch them back to
back maybe
i don't know maybe we should do that
like as it gets close you know because
christmas is still like you know four
weeks away maybe like very near
christmas we can just watch them like
one
after the other yeah but you know
because you know that first one makes a
pretty strong impression on you so it's
hard
you know like i said that's a tough act
to follow yeah
i mean anything with crustal in it and
like i said that
you know with goldie hawn having like a
more expanded role i really liked that i
really liked that they
you know showed more stuff and they
showed like more [ __ ] that she could do
like i said she's got like
magical cookies the first one sticks
with you because it's more of a classic
christmas story about
get getting the presents out to the kids
and this and that just the pacing of it
and it happened on earth and it all
happened on earth so it feels like a
christmas movie
very much so this one doesn't feel as
christmassy
yeah it's it's something taking place in
the north pole
they don't really talk about getting
christmas and making christmas it's it's
trying to save they're just trying to
save uh
santa's village yeah like the sand
village so it's a little bit different
it's more just like and
christmas is coming but it's like not
right you know like
five seconds until christmas it's like
the week before christmas i don't even
know if they say like exactly
they never did say yes but yeah it's
like christmas is coming up but it's not
like
so it's not quite the same christmas eve
night like that
creatively that might have been the way
to go
because imagine if you were to watch
them back to back which i think a lot of
people christmas will end up doing
yeah um you know because the first one
is such a classic i feel like people are
going to start like watching it every
year
and then if you start watching them both
every year if they were like too similar
then right you wouldn't want to be
repetitive right yeah that's just the
way it is i mean you know
so we'll add this to the rotation as
well usually i don't watch
well i don't want to say i don't watch
the same things every christmas but i do
like to watch all the christmas
mystery science theater episodes like
right around christmas time um
you know santa claus uh santa claus
conquers the martians and then what was
the newer one they did the christmas
that almost wasn't that
that was like on the netflix show yeah
that was a [ __ ] weird ass movie
so yeah i like to watch those i like to
watch at least one of the
christmas carols uh the muppet one's
good
or the one with alistair sim or the one
with uh george c
scott those are the best ones i think
but you know
some people like the mr magoo one
i've never seen anything i saw the mr
magoo one but it was like a really long
time ago you never saw like muppet
christmas carol or
no remember there's a claymation one
that had mr freeze and all that remember
that
yes that was from the 60s i think some
of those yeah i like all those rank and
bass
like stop-motion like they had like
rudolph the red-nosed reindeer
um and then there was one the one with
the little
mr heatmiser and all that i think that
was rudolph's shiny new year
maybe yeah i think that was a new year
one they had good songs from whatever
yeah yeah everybody remembers a little
heap miser song like the little guy with
like the little flames on his head or
whatever
i don't see that one as often like you
can see the christmas one i think they
show the christmas one like the grinch
and the
you know the peanuts christmas and stuff
they show those every year yeah but i
don't know like the
rudolph shiny new year i haven't seen
like probably since i was a teenager
it's been so long because i'm pretty
sure that's the one that has a little
heat miser on it
mark of the devil says that one thumbs
down must be steven seagal yeah that
[ __ ] is always like
maybe he's always watching or he's like
[ __ ] he's like
i'll show you [ __ ] tom
except he gets somebody else to push the
doubt
he gets a rush he gets a russian sex
slave to push
he can't even yeah he can't even give us
a thumbs down by himself he has to tell
somebody else baby do me a favor
give tom a thumbs down he's [ __ ]
i can't lean forward i beat his [ __ ]
ass
he's gonna sit on your head and fart
i was talking people into watching
[ __ ] under siege last night yeah
under siege is a good one though they're
trying to get me to talk about steven
seagal man that's what they're trying to
do we we're kind of talking about steven
seagal
but he's always an entertaining topic
though yeah like i said i gotta get a
steam seagull costume
you should yeah i should make one a
little shiny shirt and a [ __ ] good
teeth
and then get some of the pillows off the
bed and stuff them underneath
paint like a [ __ ] black v do it oh my
god
i can have little round spectacles like
he has like those little kind of yellow
yeah and then start speaking in a fake
chinese accent he's just like
multi-racial
whatever race he needs to be at any
given time
whoever he's talking to he's italian
he's black
he's chinese he's cajun he's [ __ ]
everything man
new yorker yeah he's what else is he god
i don't even
know he can just he's any voice he needs
to be
at any moment he's [ __ ] something
else man man of a thousand voices
yeah i think it's just a trait of a
[ __ ] pathological liar they just
looking
i think so terrible yeah they just
become whoever they're like chameleons
need to become whoever they need to be
at the minute
yeah i don't even know if he does it
like on purpose i don't think he does it
on purpose
like he's just like so used to i think
it's just normal for him because
hey baby can you do me a favor and hand
me some of that asian experience
thank you baby you know i love you pour
it in the pool
[Laughter]
yeah baby that shit's getting all up in
her punani yeah yeah
the asian experience green all the penny
poon and he's swimming in it
it's all nice and wet swimming
she's going to get a urinary tract yeah
[Laughter]
this took a turn didn't it all right we
weren't talking about kurt russell
played santa claus and now we're talking
about stephen's goal
drinking me out of a bowl i don't know
how that happens
[ __ ] tom tripping yeah you are yeah
all right so uh
yeah netflix right now has christmas
chronicles too
check it out tell me what you think
watch them both back to back
um as i said i don't think i don't see
how anyone could
would like this one better than the
first one because the first one like i
said is
amazing and it's a classic but this
one's like pretty good too and i'm glad
they kind of did a different thing with
it
um so i guess that'll do it for today's
matinee i'm gonna go get some pumpkin
pie because i haven't had any yet
yep because i ate a different kind of
pie apple pie on thanksgiving that i
just hadn't have any [ __ ] pumpkin pie
yet so i'm gonna go god said the [ __ ]
hold on one second khan vozland jumps in
says [ __ ] seagal is a fascinating
heterosexual
he's the original heterosexual he
invented that [ __ ]
and matter of fact when you are a
heterosexual you are violating you you
are violating his copyright
you owe him money being a heterosexual
he invented that [ __ ]
oh you know what you should you should
do that if he does not have a copyright
on being a heterosexual then you should
do that and then everybody has to give
you money
yeah the king of straits they call me
the king of straits
[Laughter]
you guys owe me royalties the king of
all strengths
yeah i'd [ __ ] be a billionaire
overnight
that's what i mean we need to like find
a way to work that out
[Laughter]
so in a way i'm pimping all these
[ __ ] out
there's another shirt every time people
[ __ ] they gotta pay me you gotta pay me
yeah that's good and see that's mexicans
in there that's mexicans in there giving
me these ideas they know how to
make money they're working this is
they're working the system i understand
that
[ __ ] you're you're a genius dude you
inspire me to make money
just by [ __ ]
oh my god yeah we need to start working
on that right now
yeah see what our options are at this
arena
[Laughter]
you know you're doing good when the
mexicans just say yeah
yeah yeah coming down
i mean he wants me to go down to tijuana
and share this money with him
let's show up to your work jair khan of
ozlon
the ulti he's a khan is the ultimate
ricardo monteblanc
for this [ __ ] generation all right
i'm gonna show up to where he works
he works at a hotel i'm gonna show up
there and [ __ ]
big old bags of money
with dollar signs just like a cartoon
that's [ __ ] money
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah all kinds of cartel members
jump out start counting it
he's got the whole scenario figured out
already yeah
they start they start exporting [ __ ]
tequila to me and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no tax stamps or nothing just comes
right across the border
no taxes paid to the federal government
we're just gonna
have the ship shipped in it'll be blue
we'll ship it in like this window washer
and then once i come here i'll use a
chemical process to turn it back yellow
again
and then i'll put it in a bottle and
[ __ ] sell it
tequila would be the finest tequila
yeah i like it i like that yeah
bring it in in trucks just huge [ __ ]
trucks up to blue tequila
yeah wiper fluid
[Laughter]
all right you're done yeah yeah
kyle said he needs a jaguar all right
i'll give you a jaguar wait like an
actual jaguar or a car one of each
yeah i would like an actual jaguar
all right we gotta go yeah we gotta have
guys
yeah [ __ ] yeah go watch some
christmas movies you know seagal is
going to try to come kick my ass
all this [ __ ] off he's going to ring the
doorbell he's going to do the door right
now where's tom
[Laughter]
i'm totally telling him where you are
dude but i'm like i'm going to i'm going
to like
videotape this time i've been tell you
keep talking [ __ ] about me
[Laughter]
i gotta take care of that i can't
understand
not this injustice
[Laughter]
musical fighting and [ __ ] no you insegal
stunt doubled yeah yes it's called stunt
double
he'll come out and whips my ass yes
let's
just stand there go and that's what you
get yeah that's right i forgot he
doesn't fight anymore he's still a
double dozen yeah that's good we're
gonna
you write that write that book jenny
okay all right it will tell you i mean i
think the only way he'd kick your ass is
if he like fell on you
i just run into a real tight circle
around him
[Laughter]
after a few minutes he gets tired
come here you little [ __ ]
oh my god i'm picturing it i'm picturing
it
somebody needs to animate that
that'd be funny and [ __ ] all right all
right we're done
yeah because my eyes are watering
because i'm laughing so hard
all right so thanks you guys for
stopping by we'll be back again tomorrow
for another live matinee show another
new movie
so uh we'll see you tomorrow bye